[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Богемка,
Причорномор'я]
Народилася, виросла і проживаю
більше п'ятдесяти років уже в цьому селі.
Мама моя чешка була,
у неї всі предки, діди-прадіди — чехи.
А тато — українець.
[Ольга Андрш
Голова чеського товариства «Богемка»]
Абонент не може...
прийняти наш дзвінок.
Вдома ми спілкувалися чеською мовою,
а з татом — українською.
Тому ось цей розподіл, коли запитують:
«А як ви навчилися української?»,
це з дому в нас вже було закладено, ми це вміли.
Людо!
[собака гавкає]
[чеською] Добрий день! Перепрошую.
— [чеською] Ось ключі.
— [чеською] Я не щодо того [прийшла].
[чеською] Перш за все нам з Вами треба домовитись,
на яку годину Ви зможете прийти.
[чеською] Не мусите бігти прямо зараз.
За півгодинки, за годинку. Зможете підійти до місця зустрічі?
— [чеською] Добре.
— [чеською]  Бо я вам туди дзвонила, а ви мене не чули. [сміється]
Наші предки покинули Чехію, так як історично нам відомо,
після поразки гуситів на Білій горі у 1620 році.
Потім почалося пригнічення віросповідання,
не хотіли передаватися католикам.
І були змушені емігрувати:
хто в яку сторону пішов.
Тьотя Зіна тут?
Вова, де наша тьотя Зіна?
— Я не знаю.
— Як це ти не знаєш?
Дівчатка, на четверту можна збирати ансамбль,
трішки поспілкуємося, поговоримо.
В архівах було знайдено,
що цю землю найняли вихідці з Чехії.
1905 рік.
Працювали у тваринництві...
До колективізації кожен мав
наділ землі, кожен мав господарство.
Мали обов'язково якусь конячку,
тому що ще не було такої техніки.
І обробляли свої землі, родинами збиралися.
Потім вже, коли була колективізація,
теж пройшов цей болючий процес як для всіх.
Хочу підкреслити,
що дуже багато чеських сіл є в Україні.
І майже всі змінили назву,
тільки Богемка від заснування залишилася Богемкою.
Ми розмовляємо не тільки чеською мовою,
от невістка зараз у нас — українка.
Але вона добре розуміє чеську,
з маленьким ми розмовляємо чеською.
Весь час у нас...
Дочка моя теж живе тут в селі,
вона має двох синів,
і теж [розмовляє] чеською мовою,
чоловік — українець,
він народився і виріс в селі,
говорити вміє чеською мовою.
Як були діти маленькі,
то він з ними чеською розмовляв.
Тобто, раніше всі в селі спілкувалися чеською,
не зважаючи, якої ти нації.
Ну, ми так вважаємо, що приблизно
половина жителів є чехами,
але, скажімо так, не повністю:
є дуже багато змішаних родин.
І тому [буває, що людина] наче напівчех,
напівукраїнець або напівмолдованин.
Це наша чесько-братська євангельська церква.
З допомогою чесько-братської євангельської церкви було збудовано ось цю будівлю.
Це наша пані Людмила Гардт.
[Людмила Гарт
Кураторка Вифлеємської каплиці в Богемці]
Вона є куратором всієї цієї будівлі.
Це — клас, зроблений для навчання дітей,
коли приїжджають влітку до нас
студенти з Чехії.
Приїжджають до нас вчителі,
які протягом чотирьох тижнів працюють з дітьми.
Вони з ними вивчають нові слова,
тому що наша чеська мова в нашому селі
і чеська мова в Чехії відрізняються.
У нас дуже багато старих слів, дуже багато українських
слів перекладено на чеську мову.
Тобто, підробили. І студенти, коли приїжджають,
працюють з дітками тут.
Був період після війни і до 1962 року,
[коли] церква не працювала.
А тепер, від 1991 року почали знову ми збиратися.
Сестра Оля поїхала в Чехію,
ми їй сказали там зайти і сказати,
що ми тут є в Україні.
Книжки привезені з Чехії волонтерами
і просто з церкви.
А на цих стелажах прикриваємо,
щоб сонце не випалювало.
Ось...
старі Біблії, що люди з собою
взяли з Чехії.
Прийшов 1991 рік:
відчули волю, захотіли збиратись.
Тоді з'ясувалося, що хочемо ще щось будувати.
Що життя наче попереду і можна будувати.
Було погоджено з чеськими братами,
і вони сказали, що допоможуть фінансово.
Наша задача була тут організувати все.
Чоловік тоді був головою колгоспу, нам було простіше організовувати.
Може ті колгоспи і не були такі хороші для землеробства,
люди були прив'язані [до місця],
мали постійну роботу,
не треба було хвилюватися,
щоб десь її треба шукати.
Тим більше нас стільки років вчили
не думати, а тепер треба думати.
А воно зараз...
Не всім вдається думати.
Колись вважалося, що ансамбль —
це як візитівка нашого села.
Тому що іншої інформації про село
ніхто не міг дізнатися.
І я, наприклад, пов'язую тільки
створення ансамблю з тим,
що було заборонено віросповідання,
люди не могли збиратися, їм треба було десь збиратися.
— [чеською] Добрий день.
[чеською] А, ще Люда там десь...
Не додзвонилася більше я до Рози.
♪ [чеською] Танцюй, танцюй, крутись, крутись, ♪
♪ [чеською] тільки мою піч не руйнуй, не руйнуй. ♪
♪ [чеською] Піч буде добра на зиму, на зиму ♪
♪ [чеською] для того, хто не має ковдри, ковдри. ♪
♪ [наспівують] ♪
♪ [чеською] Для того, хто не має ковдри, ковдри. ♪
♪ [чеською] Стоїть солдат на варті, на варті, ♪
♪ [чеською] у розірваному пальті, пальті. ♪
♪ [чеською] Роса на нього падала, падала, ♪
♪ [чеською] від вечора до ранку, до ранку. ♪
♪ [наспівують] ♪
♪ [чеською] Від вечора до ранку, до ранку. ♪
[розмовляють між собою]
[собака гавкає]
Вийшла заміж за чеха!
[Олена Гарт
Учасниця ансамблю «Богемські фраєрки»]
Приїхала з українського села,
вивчила чеську мову.
Загалом, вчила чеську мову, більш літературну, тому що хотіла знати чеську мову.
Зараз багато змішаних родин,
так що розмовляють і чеською, і українською.
Мабуть як хто в тебе — чи приїхав хтось з родичів,
то одразу просто переходять [на іншу мову], переключаються.
Щоб було таке, як сире пюре.
Ну, кажуть, що страви подібні,
[лише] їх називають трішки інакше.
Ми кажемо «клуски».
Досить подібне тісто є... Кльоцки готують.
Що поляки щось готують таке,
що, кажуть, щось подібне є в угорців.
Я особисто цього не куштувала,
тому не знаю.
Можливо, воно є щось подібне,
а, можливо, це просто назва.
Не знаю.
На десяту годину сходимо в церкву.
А потім...
Ну, зранку щось уже підготується.
Наприклад, натреться картопля, а, можливо,
відвариться й перемелеться, як ми вже трішки підготувалися.
М'ясо підтушиться.
Воно вже майже підтушилося.
Потім ми сходимо в церкву
на десяту годину, на службу.
А потім прийдемо...
У багатьох сім'ях це може відбуватися навіть так,
що прийдуть просто діти,
і накриється такий смачний стіл.
Про щось поговориться взагалі,
тому що зазвичай вже різні сім'ї,
то такі посиденьки цікаві виходять.
Ми там можемо затриматися годинки
до четвертої іноді, можливо навіть і пізніше.
— Як у кого...
— Так.
Ми можемо накрити стіл чеською кухнею,
можемо накрити стіл українською кухнею.
До речі, у мене ще 25% молдавської крові,
тому ми можемо і мамалиги зварити.
Так що тут взагалі немає проблем.
Хотілося б, щоби наша громада
діяла на тому рівні, як зараз.
Щоб не падав той ентузіазм.
Щоб якось протриматися ще трохи,
щоб і наші діти мали що розповідати потім.
Онуки навіть, щоб мали що розповідати.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Макс Салій (Завалля), Сергій Розов]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія створена за підтримки Агенства США
з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]